[Music]
to know
yellow tree nothing there's no
[Music]
yellow
there's no
[Music]
was I
there's no
[Music]
there
69 now it's time for new believable
people and we must do it if we don't
control insiders this will be over and
over to lead it by an a big fat love
like common ground to halt the spread of
lies and we must do it big fat love it's
lies fatal we want to build a much
better believable people and we must do
it
non-fatal communication very much higher
America first to lead it by an any
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders for
of insiders five acres
time to stop insiders fighting for
insiders America first 69 now it's time
for you
believable people and we must do it if
we don't control insiders this will be
over and over to lead it by an anti
common ground to halt the spread of
lives
and we must do it big families love it's
like common ground to halt the spread of
lies fatal we want to build a much
better believable people and we must do
it not fatal communication very much
higher America first to lead by an any
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders more
of insiders fighting for insight
time to stop insiders fighting for
insiders America
[Applause]
[Music]
you
and the future never comes
for what
and the future never comes what comes is
always here now and because of
[Music]
and the future never comes what comes is
always
[Music]
[Applause]
you could have lived but you only plans
and because of
[Music]
every time
there's embossing some dogs and dogs and
bears and horses and dogs
[Music]
watch this
hearing something and that list of this
[Music]
reaching out recording painful
this is watching
[Music]
listen this right here man it was like
alarms
[Music]
right now there it is again
reaching out and hurting people
[Applause]
this is what
[Music]
I like that don't you
[Applause]
[Music]
there it is again so strong
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and Betty
[Music]
in the house we all opposed where we had
to quarantine all along
and on the pause her demands from the CD
feet so we chose
Warren paint and we'll give
or the MA
I'll show the fries
we are live in cold the quarantine a
cold
quarantines at least you'll have
the month of warranty
but the Florentines now we all have
extra my horrible
butjust man
I should know
they're unrelated
we are live
a cold
a cola corentin´s credit I come / mud
club to join $30 off by using the promo
code quarantine the entire month of
April all of the content is here on
YouTube because we know you're going
nuts
[Music]
I'm doing I'm the maestro and by the way
I went to go see actually a symphony for
Christmas this year
really I am 99% convinced that most of
this is bullcrap I mean playing the
wrong like this it's all pacing right
bill is just keeping everyone on time
yeah I know but I don't believe it
speaking of which when we use a lovely
intro from smooth Manny yeah the
birthday smooth Manny and two pops
Crowder yeah love you both but I hate
your country the country of Colombia
aside from aside from coffee and Shakira
I think he's a little bit of inside
baseball and some of the bias going on
with the kovat stuff from the youtubes
my half-asian lawyer is here how are you
sir I'm glad to be here Richmond I
should say oh wait wait a second before
I introduce Gerald uh which one I didn't
even know anymore well yeah let's go
with L he'll still is the Mudd Club
quarantine months
yes I'm Muslim quarantine enter in the
promo code quarantine at louder with
Crider comm / Mudd Club you get $30 off
that's our biggest discount to the Vox
ad pocalypse were not first responders
but we can create more content so we're
doing everything in front of the pay
well you can go to the schedule on the
website to see all the live streams that
we're doing and now Monday Wednesday
Friday in the morning we doubled the
content for you sitting like this like
like Cameron
and Gibby came and he said you look when
Steve and you look bad fun to do take
some pepto-bismol be a man and come pick
me up
quarterblack Garrett is here hopefully
you changed your pants and audio Wade
too cute maddie is doing the overlay
she's back she's feeling better and
she's so cute that I just threw up a
little but I swallow a little bit and
Gerald a is here how are you sir I'm
doing well sir we have a we have Donald
Trump's tro cab really and that cares
Quran is correct I hear it
and it's scientifically sound the
approved question of the day before we
go on and I ran this past half-asian
bill beforehand crap on China he's like
I get it
so approved what are you what is worst
offense by the way we're not just
talking we're not we're talking mainly
about the Chinese government but eating
pets would that be up there dangerous
viral experimentation lying about the
pandemic or fentanyl you let me know but
first before we move on with a lot of
news of the day China actually giving
credit where it's due
they're finally stepping up their
coronavirus efforts
[Music]
magical now we know where Governor Cuomo
gets his ideas razor bump was it a
barbell Korean plungers that was nice it
was entertaining hey hey I looked good
in that video that's racist we don't
tell it on the show by the way before we
get started obviously you may be
familiar with our motions graphics
designer Brent even Brendan we talked
with him on Wednesday Wednesday morning
because his family came into town to
visit him on all across the entire
country it's good timing and so we've
had to take precautions because there is
a likelihood as slim as it may be that
he came in contact with a corona virus
so let's go down to our security camera
we've taken the proper precautions
everyone there is working and then and
there you go there is Brendan good okay
no that's fine hey Brandon you got to
put the mask on buddy you can't you
can't ET
I don't give a microbes don't know if
you're eating put the mask on it doesn't
work if it's on your neck for crying out
loud make the code makes it very
difficult I guess all at risk
it makes it difficult when your
employees are that's true
that's very true sir yeah we'll make
sure he's okay both physically and
emotionally your birthday Brendon shut
up hopefully he gets his check from the
government you knew this was coming by
the way a Canadian movie now the first
it's called corona it's the first kovat
19 release it explores the Chinese virus
discrimination and the ripple effects
therein and it was shot last month in
fact it is we go now I think we actually
have an early look at the trailer huh
[Music]
nature nature
good lord
[Music]
you know I told you to switch to Bill
when he dies that is the favorite thing
I've ever seen every it was short it was
sweet we much like me we actually at
were like no we could really use a
woman's voice for Lord and we we asked
to cute Maddie and without explaining
the entire context she was very truth
[Laughter]
sorry logic pro what does it have
logitech Logitech mega you should be
grateful that we're here with you and
not broadcasting from a Skype if you
want that go to Samantha P for 19 $30
off and if you are a member of course
please do renew it keeps us afloat by
the way well Jim's they're mainly closed
all my friends closed I think all of our
gyms are closed bills uh we don't go to
the gym the coronavirus though it's not
stopping Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
from working out according to her
personal trainer though DC has been shut
down the Justice quote ain't havin it
mmm and her personal trainer and you
know he's actually he's even been
sharing her workouts on Instagram which
you can see here she is
I wanna buy what she's selling which
coincidentally is my fifty oh I like
those little sweat bands on the wrists
difference you know it's it's more of us
it's more of a fashion statement when
you no longer have sweat glands yeah
yeah I really you know it is just for
the works yes it really is it's like leg
warmers she doesn't have any legs no
legs so finally in these trying times by
the way everyone's been affected by this
we're gonna go China in a little bit and
then Tim Poole I'm really looking
forward to talking with Tim pool because
there's over yeah there's been
don't on social media yeah everyone's
been tested here even celebrities a
little bit but some of them been really
helpful up for example Nickelback
they've stepped up with a signed guitar
Nickelback guitar really for charity
general though I should be clear Costco
has made it clear they're limiting the
guitar to one per customer
[Music]
don't take more than 100 other yeah we
do right now the difficulty hoarding
like that doesn't wear also I should
mention on that same website Creed
singer Scott Stapp is selling one of his
guitars as well
who's in joint you get it and into the
you know she's surprisingly really easy
we were all just we broke backwards from
how can we write a bit where we
physically shun nickel too on-the-nose
right right now well I just spread a
little next to the no you got a little
something what is it scott stapp just
you got it by the way before you
actually get it be including some we
only do live chats by the way with
people who are mug Club members on
Monday Wednesday Friday next Tuesday
Jean he probably will be live streaming
with the nog de Naga Dena live yeah
Tuesday so much fun nice - call of duty
which Call of Duty's yankie gonna be
stream or zone I don't know but the
point is he just said that it was but if
you want to chat with us we don't use
YouTube live chat because don't pay
nothing so you can share through mug
Club before we move on don't actually
think one less time let's check back in
with our good friend even Brendon
Brendon how are you Brennan you know
you've been working hard I appreciate it
go grab yourself a break a cup of water
yeah okay yeah I know it's tough it's
been tough for you and then no no six
feet for the CDC Manny's right there
Brendan does birthday yeah come on man
now six feet Brendan Brendan get
yourself some water but but six feet hmm
yeah okay don't get mad at me Brent I
don't make the rules I just call them
isn't that right
yeah feels true you got to go to enforce
them and I have to collect his check
from the government I look I already
said if you need to turn the power up on
the shot-caller I know we will
you know what and it's not it's it's not
fair it's not fair for his own good up
here for you to have to do that have to
do that hey quarterblack before I move
on let's bring up the the tweets of the
week here I think we have some pictures
of you and all these folks that's great
thank you so much so look at the blue
eyes on that lady right there
I can't tell Jenna that blue eyes my
eyes are more of his like a like a a
listless taupe
what it has like the walls of an
abandoned hospital you're somewhere like
a doll's eyes yeah I don't know why
you're watching how lazy they're
late-night host are oh yeah and I get it
they can't cut they have employees if I
get they have 150 writers so I
understand they could get adjusted they
could get a snowball mic or a Yeti mic
if they're gonna be broadcasting from
home I'll be helpful I love let's get
and you're gonna have actually a half
agent bill has some context on this
originally this was titled because he's
turning what if he's China but we was we
realize it didn't delineate enough
between the Chinese government the
Chinese people and try to talk about
that that being said there's still are
some issues that I have outside of the
Chinese government to a degree not a lot
but let's talk about this right now
everything wrong with China and not just
as a part of this pandemic right now
right but I think if nothing else is
sort of lifted the veil for a lot of
people to realize like hey as far as
international trade goes as far as the
agreements they're not necessarily our
friends in every country I mean they're
necessarily enemies I don't want to be
the Lucian you should be American by
American I mean have you have you driven
a volt I have a triple-a in japan toyota
salesman he's a my god
so point is now that I said that we can
dump on China so Donald Trump has been
trying to sound the alarm
particularly as it relates to
international trade on China for quite
some time I'd like to have you take a
look at the event and all that's coming
out of China and Mexico major Chinese
drug traffickers forges strip and they
have really put very very strong clamps
on them they've indicted them we're
almost a chokeslam
five percent for a car to go in and we
charge two percent for their car to come
into the United States that's not good
we've tax China on three hundred billion
dollars worth of goods and products
being sold into our country he said he
was going to stop fentanyl from coming
into our country it's all coming out of
China now I just think eiders and I've
talked about this I don't like the idea
of tariffs because it's a tax passed on
to the consumer
however right there is a valid point
when you do have countries in it's no
longer equitable if they are taxing our
goods going over and this happened at
one point I believe too with Japan's and
Japan and there aren't several Japan's
but what Japan was doing with
motorcycles and unfortunately we did it
with Honda's that were coming in and it
was actually a Ronald Reagan who did
this I understand it being equitable but
the flipside is a lot of Americans had
to buy Harley's and if I'm not mistaken
the AMF days where they didn't work at
all so this didn't have access to good
motorcycles but there does need to be a
balance of making sure a lot of people
we aren't competing with slave labor and
you have I mean you still have relatives
uh yeah so I've got I mean I've got some
family who are in Hong Kong and I
actually had a cousin who even though
born in the United States worked
extensively in China and what's really
interesting is just the different the
different ways in which China has kind
of spoken out of both sides of his mouth
right at one point it'll say yeah oh
well no we're we're we're very Pro the
wet markets oh no no no now we're
against them we're shutting them all
down rather than the same time they're
tiding traditional medicine which uses
the animal products the wildlife animals
from the wet markets and all the while
you have you have pockets of Chinese
citizens and scientists who are saying
are you kidding me why can't we just
shut these down and join the wrong move
on to what markets but I meant more so
with trade right as more Libertines we
agree like listen we shouldn't be just
putting a tariff on to punish a country
but right if they are punishing us we
really isn't a fair international trade
agreement and I think and no one no one
by the way but Bernie Sanders talked
about this Hillary the Clintons talked
about this a long time ago I know NAFTA
we can go into Oakland but if you listen
to Hillary Clinton's rhetoric but
certainly Bernie Sanders
Trump's the first person to do anything
as it relates to trade that's not what
we're talking about today but it has
sort of fostered an environment with
this festering pustule that has become
the Chinese communist government yeah
for everybody who is giving Donald Trump
a hard time about the tariffs I get it
but what do you do when you have a
trading partner like that that refuses
to play about any rules that's stealing
people's ID as soon as they come to the
country and doing whatever they want
with it like what what do you do if
that's not the solution okay fine what
do you do no administration before this
has done a good job dealing with them
right none and the only one to stand up
and they have the purchasing power of 19
billion people that's true they even
understand their people in the census
that's crazy yeah absolutely is now so
going back to Bill's point China this
week they reopened the wet markets that
were allegedly the source of this and by
the way well you're still selling bats
dogs and cats and I want to be clear and
I try to be really careful by the way I
want to warn you we're not showing
anything graphic as far as videos but to
me it's still disturbing it's really
hard for me to do any of the animal
stuff so yeah I'll let me describe it
for you and then tell you you're not
going to see anything other than dogs
and cages at the market but I do think
it's important to ride this home to
understand this sort of severity
I mean okay okay it's tough to make sure
the clip isn't that isn't that bad they
reinstated the wet markets right okay
what markets allegedly from what we
understand create a virus and now while
the rest of the world is still going
through the pandemic they reinstated
them to understand the severity that
imagine the United States removing all
the social distancing guidelines and
then banning soap that's how severe
bringing back wet markets can be no
hygiene standards the cruelty though is
it's over the top dogs are kept in
cramped cages and then I'm not going to
show it but then they're boiled alive I
want to warn you it's not graphic but
the following footage will make you
angry
[Music]
we had to cut it short because we can
join without you guys getting super
super piss yeah now now bill
what does wet market mean I don't mean
to ask you slowly do and you're asking
the Asian half so it'll be okay yeah
accurate so so what people have always
understood what markets to be and what
they've always been described as is the
wet refers to the blood people are going
to be scanning the animals alive or
butchering them live on the street in
front of the customers and they like wet
work a military term you know
assassinations that's I think it refers
to the blood that's involved but now
actually people are trying to swing the
other way to try to counter the racism
of just the facts of the situation of
how these wet markets exist there was an
LA Times article came out either today
or yesterday that tried to say well it's
not actually referring to the blood in
the butchering it's just referring to
the fact that they hose the ground off
and the ground is wet wet with the blood
of the animal that we're getting old
alive because apparently that makes them
more delicious yeah
and I know we told not all Chinese
people support the idea of what markets
but here's the thing sure it's enough
there are enough people that this can
have been in a public square I mean for
example if you show up with a manga hat
here in the United States an TIFF is
gonna show up to punch you in the face
no one is there pulling a Jesus with the
temple just knocking crates over like
you're free yeah I want us I want to see
wet market Willard by the way this is
important one really important thing to
there are knows there are no civilized
cultures none none outside of Asia that
eat dogs I want to be really clear about
this because I understand the eating
cats thing and not just do they don't
like cats but cats have not always been
domesticated animals to this degree that
dogs have been I understand when people
now say oh pigs you can why do you eat
pigs that's wrong because a lot of
people have pigs as pets I can
understand that cultural differences
since the dawn of human civilization
dogs have been our eyes our ears and the
senses that we do not have we have
always had an alliance no other society
outside of Asian societies eat dogs
except and I did a lot of research on
this a couple of societies in like the
Swiss Alps and these are really they're
basically like try this basically Swiss
ready
family Olson's that's all they are man
if I this is an issue that it's like
there is a cruelty to killing in animals
yeah that is innately affectionate
toward humans yeah and then the way that
they do it too but lest you think that
these wet markets exist in the
countryside because you think oh it's
got to be removed no the Wu Han area
where these wet market it's a 15 million
person City right centre it's like you
gotta get in downtown New York
right right right around everybody
that's packed together so it's not like
an isolated thing out in the country
right go to it just so you know the
numbers I mean it's tens of thousands of
markets oh yeah market I mean and at its
peak before they started shutting them
all down which was not long ago months
ago we're writing about there were tens
of thousands of these markets and even
in not just in the quote/unquote rural
provinces which is a good point Gerald I
mean these are multiple million person
cities yeah but even in Shanghai or
Beijing or in the suburbs around those
towns they have those wet markets and
you know it's again it's not just the
idea of a butcher right like we have
butchers here and do live butchering but
it's the proximity of wild animals all
together will combined with the hygiene
and the mixing that creates the huge
problem that we right here yeah yeah and
that's a good point
tens of thousands that's it's not like a
Michael Vick dogfighting ring where you
hear about it in the United States yeah
and everyone is horrified and the guy
basically loses his pass to society
right people walk by a dog being boiled
alive there and well that seems about
right yeah Tuesday this is something
important this has been a threat
globally that has been talked about for
a while but not in mainstream media
because Russia Russia Russia so we can't
talk about it there's only so much air
time we have to know about Cuomo's
nipple rings and his brothers alfredo
recipe so let's go through a few points
here that I think of matter in in
relation to China in half-asian bill you
can half correct me wherever I'm wrong
good only have the white markets they're
not only where coronavirus started also
SARS yeah let's let's be clear about
that and those are just the diseases
that originated specifically in the wet
market so all meant not all but many
different strains of bird flu okay swine
flu they spread in these markets they
didn't they weren't create it
necessarily as markets but this is where
they spread these and they led to
repeated outbreak and I know
going to say and I've read this I don't
know where I read this but said well you
know just because these diseases started
there just like I mean I United States
started Lyme disease it's true there's a
big difference between a disease started
in a in a cruel market with a dog both
alive from a cage and a tick bite that
yell from an oak tree we really want to
compare this sure that's on us
sorry about the Ozarks and the Lyme
disease okay
I mean there's there's a clear
difference between something that occurs
in nature is something that is
repeatedly year after year decade after
decade allowed to happen not just
through inaction but through actually
touting these policies that encourage
the kind of conditions in which not just
one SARS came out but the current
Llorona
is a version of SARS right now it's like
this hasn't happened before and the
Chinese government has before stepped in
and immediately said we're shutting it
all down that's the most important thing
to me right and we have this isn't over
they've shut down these markets during
they shut them down during the SARS
outbreak during the age seven and nine
which I don't necessarily remember it
was we knew about birds that's what we
knew about bird flu that was a pandemic
it was and now coronavirus so what's
most important to me is they shut them
down right so this disease spreads they
shut down the web Marcus I get railway
market okay and then they reopen them so
they know that it's happening there and
right now it's extra dickish because the
pandemic is still spreading across the
globe and they are already reopening
them like can't you wait until the
bodies have assumed room temperature in
Italy in Spain and the United States
before you reopen what you knowingly had
as it created as an incubator to create
the proliferation of this disease that's
what bothers me
there-there is no ignorance isn't a
defense you told me about that before
when I was a I don't know they don't
even get that or you knew and I will say
this not all cultures are created equal
okay I believe that the American culture
is better than the culture that has live
wet markets as a general or certainly
that component of our culture yeah look
and if you say and there's been another
article bill came out that I read that
said that this is part of Chinese
culture and we need to make sure that we
don't get rid of it completely because
of livelihoods and everything else and
I'm like okay well I can understand the
argument to a degree but let's let's at
least say if you're gonna have this kind
of a market I disagree with some of the
animals that you have there right I'll
never agree with that but the other
stuff at least we have those animals I
disagree we're having them there I heard
I disagree with a lot of Henry not at
all so I you have to have regulation
there because they tested so the problem
was with the washing they would put
these animals into these these baths
it's almost like this communal bath to
clean them off and they tested the water
and they just kept reusing it and
reusing them using it that's where all
the viruses are all right we got every
single one move on from the wet market
it's credible point made I think and you
know what don't worry you'll get that
those animals he's a clever little
bastard so let's go down some other
dangerous things that I've been going
the research okay so if the wet markets
weren't bad enough Chinese government
they've been conducting all kinds of
viral research oh yeah right they've
been isolated and worked with over 2001
my shirt yeah over 2000 new viruses
including bat coronaviruses just three
miles from the Wuhan market you were
saying actually some of them are of one
point two kilometers one point two
kilometers away what a Washington Times
put up there that it was three but I
actually just Google Earth it but the
Chinese government or somebody removed
from Google the listing of where that
that's interesting I would like to know
why there's that fine discrepancy I
wonder if it's the way of the bird no so
one point is useful answers walking
really walking you can look it up right
now
well I don't want to look it up right
now saying like the people at home can
all trust you over Washington you should
definitely do that they're researching
viruses deadly viruses call it three
miles to be generous now if it's one
point two kilometers that's about half a
miles closed how do you like growing
organic turnips next to area 51 yeah
that's not a good idea
it's not a good turnips and this isn't a
race thing it's a bad idea thing don't
study deadly viruses next to where
people eat live things yes oh and by the
way there's a a hospital right across
the street from this place as well you
know there was there's actually a paper
by it what does it sound like I'm a
Technical Institute that came out it's
been out for a couple of months just got
recently updated they are
like I would know it like South China
technically - slippers on Sunday let me
anyone else getting the feeling that
Gerald likes talks the because something
tells me you would find a hard drive
full of Chinese pornography no my
Chinese government contacts said that
you're on some list over there well I
should be by now but what they're saying
is that they actually don't think that
there is any evidence that it came from
the market meaning originated there
they're saying that they're the only
evidence they have is tissue samples
that were being worked on at this Center
for Disease Control in China this is not
a conspiracy theory they're saying that
the closest habitat for these bats is
over 900 kilometers away the bats that
they say caused a and we're not being
sold at the market at the time from
these scientists coming from an inside
source by the way i'm tryna get some
colloidal silver which will kill the
strain directly it's a hundred percent
you said you thought that it came from
the lab look I think that there's a
chance that the lab was it's all in one
capacity or another but I will say may
not be nefarious so it may have been an
accident yes I'm not saying there's no
like intentional release or even right
like intentionally creating biological
weapons or anything like that but you
know when you say it out loud like that
it doesn't sound so far
you say the Chinese binding shoe fits
so the like I said earlier the issue is
it's bringing all these things together
so if you're bringing animals with
difference all animals have diseases and
a time and time again a lot of these
very pandemic inducing diseases come
from and what frankly an unholy
combination or proximity of unhygenic
animals and people and butchering
processes or even other types of things
like that right and when you put them
all together frequently frequently
frequently it's just it's not does it
mean today it's gonna be bad or
tomorrow's move on or next month but
you've increased the chances that
something's going to spread animal day
let me see something else too this is
important we're not just pointing out
cruelty because we don't like no cruelty
actually does have a dramatic effect on
the health of these animals in the
immune system like people want to talk
about factory farming United States
that's why they have to inject it with
all kinds of antibiotics because their
close proximity your dog is dirt your
dog is filthy enough they lift a crotch
and then try and lick your face like I
get it and kind of when it's your own
dog most people are fine with it I
understand but that's not what's
happening with these dogs when you put
them in a cage and they're basically
being abused their entire lives they are
going to be more fertile carriers for
disease and to give you just so you know
this isn't necessary everything that
you've all said here is reasonable and
now I'm starting to think yeah
biological worker but I would never but
in 2013 we wouldn't says Chinese
researchers they created a mutated
strain of the the bird flu and their
attempts to make this is this is quote
attempts to make strains in a lab that
would if accidentally released are used
for nefarious purposes pose a
potentially global health threat now I'm
saying they were dealing with a
possibility they weren't they weren't
like playing it coy like they were just
saying that hey if this were to happen
it would be really bad yeah and they
were acknowledging that we're doing all
of these things that hopefully this look
have you seen Jurassic Park 1 through 5
this never works out what I've only seen
Jurassic Park 7 really it's amazing it
just takes place that was not only in a
Walmart Oh
exclusive Chinese release oh yeah
there's one more in China coal boom
saying rife finds a way by the way hit
the notification valve if you are not
subscribed or not joining my club
despite Mudd Club quarantine month hit
all notifications yeah and of course
subscriber credit bits we have new
videos that go up every night at 9 p.m.
Eastern anyway here on YouTube so
there's always a clip on YouTube that's
a full show here's another thing that I
think is pretty important when we're
talking about China and because the
media is not doing it they're carrying
their water I'll tell you why I think
the meteor come the Canadian are
communist sympathisers I'm not gonna
walk that back at all right now no but
I'll circle back to that because unless
you shut it off I just did advertise
colloidal silver and say that they were
economies let's get to the masks the
test kits that the equipment right
here's the thing there's been they've
not been honest we now know this when it
comes to medical testing right with the
krona but now everyone is acknowledging
that we were throttled on youtube for
saying you cannot trust the numbers
coming out of China right now we didn't
say that they are flat-out wrong but you
can't trust them no yet and of course
YouTube Twitter Facebook they decided to
redirect all of these kinds of
statements to more authoritative sources
some of which were directly from the
Chinese communist government oh by the
way Donald Trump said we're not taking
the masks everyone gave him crap for it
the Netherlands yeah they had to recall
600,000 Wow faulty masks from China the
latest test kits from Spain they only
work 30% of the time same for the kids
Turkey
yeah country after Dare scrambling to
try and dump some of these bad Chinese
products that are destroying the chances
of taking the coronavirus out or at
least containing it here think about
this for a second take all the numbers
from these countries and then add
potentially 30% yeah you're talking
about the infection rates yeah we're the
only country that doesn't have that
right now we have more accurate testing
right now yeah and now we're doing more
and more testing by the day the fact I
was shocked I had to double check this
and have read your research a 30 percent
failure rate
that's insane what do you use our condom
what have 30 percent failure rate yeah
thirty percent of the time that's what
he's saying so it's a 70 percent failure
is what they had oh the only only work
30 percent I'd try knees I can't do math
we'd be up in arms it was 70 percent
failure and the Chinese government in
Spain basically the embassy said well I
just they weren't license to make the
product so so our bad asbestos might
want to avoid that for a while the best
by day not really relevant it's all bad
they do have a history by the way of
sometimes China exporting goods that I
was making sure about that poisonous
toothpaste yeah that toxic children's
toys yeah unsafe tires all of which had
to be recalled now I want to be really
clear not all cha not all Chinese goods
are bad and not all American goods are
good so and by the way if there's an
American manufacturer out there who can
actually create a quality mug for us we
would love to work with you it just has
to be at a reasonable rate and decent
quality at that time we could only find
American made mugs and it was more
expensive so we said we'll bring it in
from a company that tests chemically
tests there are there their products and
now we have Americans who are etching it
and painting it so it created more jobs
but if there is an American manufacturer
who can make this kind of a mug we would
love to partner with you yeah and if you
want a big old fat contract emit missus
pandemic there are a lot of new mug club
sign up so thank all of you are you
about to say something that no no no
you're good keep going keep rolling well
that's one thing to again made in the
USA sometimes can also mean crap yes yes
but we've talked about that with Harley
Davidson you you're not um you're not a
huge for a Harley Davidson you say
there's great products from other
countries in this case China just keeps
sending us crap kind of repeat I don't
believe that all American products are
the best especially when you compare for
example American cars with Japanese cars
right look at the costs that go in for
LASIK and dental and unions per retiree
we need to be clear about that but it's
also very difficult to make the argument
that Americans can compete effectively
with a country that employs slave labor
when you look at it and again that's a
problem with the Chinese government the
problem right here is not with some some
products being faulty because he could
have the same thing made in the country
so a problem was with the Chinese
government recognizing that and sending
them
internationally anyway yeah and we're
not taking a dump on American products
when we say that they're substandard we
want them to be so far no some I don't
want everyone out there to say you know
hey made in China means crap but
American products we want you to make
great stuff so that it can compete with
the rest of the world right so when we
hold your feet to the fire that's why
what do you think when you see made in
USA made in China bill it doesn't matter
yeah I mean look it's a global economy
things are made in China right they're
good some are not good same in the US I
mean yeah it's a different it's apples
and oranges when you compare right the
economy here and all the things I mean
there are a number of people who want to
hate on America and say you know that we
there are so many bad things that are
happening but when you think about why
we have to why we have to charge more
why we have certain standards of living
that are much better and we're not the
source of global pandemics I mean yeah
you know I get it there's a different
balance there's a number of people in
China who are allowing this to continue
to happen and a lot of those people are
government they want to keep yeah they
they want to keep the pristine view that
they think they have about how they're
treating their people and to continue to
have a global economy be the engine
that's sending a lot of products around
the world but it's gonna take the
Chinese people to say we we got to do
something different I hope I pray to God
and I mean it that we see in armed
insurrection from the Chinese people
against those commie bastards at some
point in their lifetime they got
overthrown are you encouraging violence
for the people who are being from there
because all of a sudden disappeared
whistleblowers right several doctors now
one tried to blow the whistle on the
mask she's gone yeah yeah I think I
think somebody will need to defend
themselves right I think people need to
rise up and hopefully the international
community rather than being paralyzed by
political correctness will say you know
what you know what these people not the
government these people deserve the same
rights that we have in France in Spain
in Italy in the United States so you
know what Chinese government because we
sympathize with your people how about
that some but some point I would like we
need to do that I'd love to hear that
press conference here's another point no
it was a vanilla fentanyl okay last mile
was what the president said fentanyl I
was like oh he's a president I must be
wrong then I realized not exactly
look is that negation the rate of
fentanyl related deaths been doubling
every year now almost 20,000 dying each
year main destination preventing the
United States main source of fentanyl
China now I know I know what you're
thinking this is a valid point you have
Americans who make meth or synthesize
opioids that's absolutely true
but those people are not creating drugs
that are effectively sanctioned or
actually subsidized by the government
and given tax breaks on exports as you
see in China yeah yeah no that actually
happens for context just imagine Joe
exotic receiving a federal grant for a
gay meth tattoo parlor Tiger Den that's
what season do it's not it's not there
the only country with drugs it's the
government actually subsidizing and
giving tax breaks no export my gosh it's
finless of what do people use fentanyl
or do they just to get high oh that god
I'm serious I don't know Rick in
jail is this innocent fentanyl is a
crazy painkiller okay and I know
interest in just over taking it well
it's so dangerous that if you put like a
grain of it in heroin the longtime
heroin user dots really yes oh it's that
potent okay it's crazy
it's not over did it it's like I inhaled
the grain of and you're dead right away
yeah it's like one grain in like 90
cases of wine would still kill you dang
it yeah yeah that's really very I knew
what the painkiller I just didn't know
how people were using it you know I will
say though we do have to get going
pretty soon fortunately President Trump
on all these points but hit particularly
fentanyl as he pronounced it he's been
he's been pretty consistent and I wish
that more people listened on all of
these points they taxed our goods going
into China it's a totally unfair deal
we've tax China on
three-hundred billion dollars worth of
goods and products being sold into our
country the Chinese virus it comes from
China yeah we already clear I I think he
has taken so much crap for calling China
out but somebody had to somebody finally
had to stand up and say look right this
isn't fair you're not dealing with the
rest of the world in a fair way and you
have to be dealt with and I don't know
why people can't see how obvious that is
can I call it can i call it right now
dollars wave that we're seeing in the
last couple of days of people main you
know mainstream media is saying we're
gonna question the China numbers oh
maybe we should not necessarily believe
the facts that are coming from this
communist government in three months
from now every one of them is gonna
forget that they said oh we should have
been hard on China and all of them are
gonna come back to those facts and say
oh that's right China was bad but they
will conveniently forget yeah during
this period they said let's keep
listening I think they think they're
communist sympathisers I think I don't
I'm not saying that the media are
communist but I will not walk this back
at all think about it for a second why
we're Washington Post New York Times Vox
all saying the flu is something should
were the corona virus is not an issue
don't worry about it now they tryna act
like it's a left-right thing no no you
guys said not to worry about it because
at that point you were parroting the
World Health Organization talking points
who by the way we're pairing the Chinese
government talking points then all of a
sudden when it was blamed on the United
States that we weren't ready because we
were trusting information from China and
a Chinese foreign minister who by the
way was not throttled or censored by
Twitter at all who are anger laws for
saying that the masks were faulty which
is true actually no she was censored
because the chloroquine thing I think I
was sense more thing than that
[Applause]
the issue was a city before was I
talking about before that oh yeah
foreign minister again the quickest
Occam's razor here why would they say
it's not a big deal and then all of a
sudden say it's a big deal and the right
is wrong about it for the same reason
that they don't seem to have a problem
with doctors and whistleblowers
disappearing in China and they refuse to
run the press briefings here in the
United States from the White House
here's a new rule while we're talking
about freedom of the press you know what
it's not exactly Communist China here if
CNN refuses to run the press briefing
and instead runs commentary on the press
briefing that you don't get a seat or a
press badge how about that how about
once you stop parroting Communist
Chinese talking points then maybe you
get a seat at that table it is
remarkable to me that I can't think of
any other time in American history but
orange man bad that we have a president
commander-in-chief who's going out there
addressing the people directly the
President of the United States and the
media is opting not to run it instead
running false propaganda that maybe
they're not getting from the Chinese
government but it certainly would be
congruent with the messages that the
Chinese government is trying to put out
there right now when you look at
reporters retweeting the Foreign
Minister with conspiracy theories for
some reason they're still on there but
Alex Jones is not this is the president
of the and something else it's
remarkable they go all potentially a
hundred thousand to two hundred twenty
thousand deaths from Corona by now you
know when you got those numbers from
Donald Trump's press briefing dummy but
you didn't run it because you didn't
want to include that we're getting
hundreds of thousands of new masks we're
getting hundreds of thousands of mask
that can be sanitized the FDA approved
the therapeutics that Donald Trump
touted and you said he was wrong and
crazy about so what do they do they
don't run the press briefing instead
they run commentary and the press
briefing while the Cuomo's talk about
their mom's pasta sauce and nipple rings
then they take the worst numbers from
the press briefings and don't actually
tell Americans about the positives
listen not all cultures are created
equal and doctor Donald Trump is right
about this just like Bernie Sanders was
right about this Americans should not
have to compete with the child at a Nike
factory who's working for a buck 50 a
day this is not we can't be at an
international economy if it's not fair
and you know what when we're talking
about this not all cultures are created
equal because I think that American
exceptionalism is a good thing and you
know if you if you boil dogs alive and
you pay children a dollar 25 or 325 a
day guess what you don't get a seat at
the International bargaining table and
not just China because not all cultures
are equal if you don't let your women
Drive you don't get to sit and dictate
any policy or even express your opinion
here in the United States if you allow
women to be beaten or they require for
witnesses for rape do we don't need to
listen to you we're not going to be on
any committee or international agreement
that you take part in so let's start
with China and then work our way down so
that hopefully we can be the end Peyer
we've been accused of being and make the
rest of the world the United States of
America why because the Chinese and
everyone else would be better off how
about that Tim Poole I think I stopped
at oh yes
[Music]
and you need to understand the clocks in
its understanding story point you really
need to understand with tags did you
enjoy tonight's open of course you did
you can thank the hundreds of underage
Chinese children animators who've been
working around the clock solely for your
help keep our Chinese animation
sweatshop open by joining mud club
during mud club quarantine month Kota
ladder with CARICOM slash mud club and
use the promo code quarantine to get $30
off a quien loss Montana's Columbiana
después de una dia largo de trabajo nada
es más de coche una casa de cafe the
black rifle coffee
[Applause]
you see a whole step
go to black raffle coffee dot-com /
brother use promo code browser for 20%
off your first purchase you desecrated
with Dan Fogelberg saw quarterblack
hello
no wait
[Music]
and mr. Krown
reason we had to rewrite many guidelines
a half a
one guy that please hang around watch
this and more at our other channel
Crowder dance
[Music]
sounds a little bit of my was a Dick Van
Dyke the love to laugh I wasn't the
other guy that was Dick Van Dyke
oh he was involved in the song right
yeah yeah I was along with the song from
I don't know if that's the kind of thing
back then were they laughing in theatres
if that that's a good people say it was
a different time yeah what is it
do people see him go I love really slate
was a simpler time no you mean stupid Oh
John I don't think people were stupid
I mean simpler they did storm the
beaches of Normandy I think they
probably had us and they also by the way
loved some like it hot which is still
funny right yeah that's true so I don't
know I'm just frustrated I'm at this
point now in the week where I really
appreciate it my Club quarantine months
but I'm frustrated I'm tired I'm going
was I thinking doing two shows a day
there's a sliver of no I'm very grateful
but there's a light in the tunnel here
for today as we kind of go to the
homestretch he of course you know him
you love him his YouTube channels he has
Tim cast and Tim cast news and you can
follow him at what the there's both
isn't there a podcast and Tim guest news
as well you're gonna correct me that's
rude he's on the Twitter while it's
allowable at Tim cast mr. Poole how are
you sir pretty good all things
considered what does that mean all
things you have AIDS do you that oh no
no but we're told not to go outside
we're told not to go to the store
we're told that you know the world's
basically ending and the economy must be
destroyed because this is virus wiping
and everything I work from home so you
know I don't know not much has changed
for me other than we have less chicken
in the freezer I guess right we're
eating more beans well I don't know
you're hacking Asian right quarter Asian
extra quarter say they have like a red
bean ice cream in those Asian countries
right so is that what you mean yeah eat
a lot ice cream well be actually a
little bit of ice cream no we went to
the storm we got beans the bean market
is a-boomin i don't know if you heard it
seriously like yeah I'm there bullish on
bean stalks
did you see Wow that's the apocalypse
food I guess I thought beans were going
bare I thought it was I thought it was a
bear market for beans
hey we move on you have a new show right
every weeknight
at 8:00 p.m. what is it yeah yeah so
youtube.com slash Tim cast IRL me and my
buddy Adam do it was supposed to be a
general interest show like we talked
about movies we're talking about the new
Sonic the Hedgehog movie and then then
the apocalypse happened and now there's
no news other than coronavirus and we're
sitting here like dude I feel you when
you were saying you're you know you're
tired or whatever however you phrase it
I'm getting so sick of every front-page
story is Kovac Kovac Kovac yeah I'm like
dude give me a Brad Pitt's shirtless you
know some celebrity gossip song man you
sure you don't have AIDS a little bit
but that's the first place you would go
that's it's actually a joke from the
show because there was one story on the
Daily Mail out of all the coronavirus
there was one tiny store and it was like
Brad Pitt took his shirt off and for
something they decided to run with it
and I'm like I'll take whatever I can
get no no no I understand I'm with you I
still you know Brad Pitt is still
responsible for these I have this scar
tissue on my gnarlie yeah really because
that shot in legends of the fall when he
comes over the hill on horseback yeah
all the time so I just get you know Brad
Pitt owes me some connection and I agree
with you on this I want to move on to
some specifics the problem is the news
media of course is all Corona Corona
Corona Corona all the time and then so
much of it needs to be corrected that a
silly late-night show like this and now
morning show has to spend time on it
because we watch CNN for an hour not one
mention of private industry stepping up
and making masks not one mention of them
being able to sanitize masks not one
mention of the FDA protection actually
no no you I'm sorry Steven you're wrong
I did take time out of their day to
insult Michael in Dell for switching his
pull production to masks and I I can't
say I'm surprised yeah you know I think
it was Jim Acosta call them the pillow
guy and like derided him for it's like
come on man yeah it sets me because
that's primarily my job I'm supposed to
make fun of the pillow rapist guy who
put some packing peanuts in a tarp and
so yeah rusted upon the American public
because Laurie Grenier from Shark Tank
likes to use Bed Bath & Beyond to sell
cheap crap but I appreciate I appreciate
that gosh this guy retooled 75% of his
factories not only is that nationally
relevant but isn't it the
of the media and certainly our leaders
to not only be truthful but to try and
find the positive amidst a pandemic
don't think there's some responsibility
yeah you know I I I'm always a little
self-critical too because I feel like a
lot of what I do and a lot of other you
know I guess media critics are we're
decently negative too but it's it's
almost it's a reaction to the media just
misleading and misrepresenting and
constantly trying to make us feel like
trash so I feel like you know to a
certain degree I deserve some blame
because then I throw the pies right back
but I don't I don't know what else you
do like I'm not gonna sit here and let
them just lie and misrepresent what's
going on and that's what they do all day
it's absurd well that's gonna happen and
I know you've talked about it in your
recent video you know they talk about
President Trump and Fox News downplaying
the coronaviruses oh that's a
conservative thing I know you're not a
conservative though unfortunately even
you've been labeled one because you have
the gall to appear on this show you
probably some insight into that it
wasn't just conservatives that was all
of mainstream media up until March
downplaying notice you know that Media
Matters ran a smear on Fox News on Jane
I believe it was January 28th saying
that they were fear-mongering about you
know the corona virus in China so you're
actually you had you had Greg Gutfeld
you had Tucker Carlson they were they
were you know they were raising the the
the red flags very early on and the
media was trashing him for it my
favorite story to go to is a Washington
Post February 4th get a grip America the
flu is way bigger threat than
coronavirus and there's a meme going
around of all of these stories from all
these mainstream media companies where
they were saying it the flu is worse
BuzzFeed I believe this was on January
28th they said don't fear the corona
virus the flu is worse and these tweets
in these posts are all still up yeah yet
now there another going to Fox News
saying AHA Hannity and you know was was
downplaying this and it's like so were
you right you know my you know my
favorite argument is there you see all
these planets coming out attacking Trump
for a slow response and okay maybe Trump
did it did have a slow response and did
a bad job I think Trump was a little
slow on this one but guess what the
Democrats didn't do anything
no they resize him for being racist when
he instituted the travel ban exactly and
they were focused on impeachment yes if
your argument to that Trump was going
too slow and that means he's not you
know he's doing a terrible
it's like okay fine I accept that that
means you did a worse job because you
were literally doing nothing but try to
impeach the guy right well he was
actually you know putting the taskforce
together think about this for a second
we've talked about this quite a bit but
let's draw a hypothetical scenario can
you imagine how the media would have
reacted during this impeachment trial if
Donald Trump said okay you know what we
are going to institute a stay in place
we're gonna put a travel ban and we're
going to invoke the defense production
act wow this is going on through
February third was Adam Schiff giving
his testimony now can you imagine how
they would have reacted had he done it
at that point there are finite resources
here guys we can't do all of it
I'll give you the headline the opinion
piece in The New York Times
Trump's desperate attempt to distract
from his you know impeachment impending
impeachment conviction right Donald
Trump earlier today tried to claim there
was a real threat to the American health
in a desperate bid to stop the unit
distract the American public once again
blah blah blah right right no you're
exactly right and I wonder how much how
much of it is is this now where they're
trying to said it's a conservative
problem and downplaying it just because
they want to sort of move on from the
impeachment trial and downplaying it for
so long so they want to put it at his
feet this was a story that I was just
commenting and I just I was just reading
it this guy from Media Matters accused
Greg Gutfeld of downpour he said Fox
News downplayed this Greg responded and
the guy called him a liar and now
there's a video clip from the
twenty-eighth of Greg saying our
administration isn't doing a good enough
job on this China's locking everything
down right and I'm like did you read the
story about how uh Kirk Carlson went
down to Florida to meet with Trump to
tell him this was a serious issue unlike
February the beginning of February
whatever right it's it's it's like you
know I think everybody was a bit slow on
this one for sure even I initially on
the 23rd of January said I didn't think
it was gonna be a big deal and I was
wrong and then I started to change my
tune when the more information came out
but I think it's fair to point out
everybody was slow on this and at a time
when BuzzFeed Washington Post and
everybody had said it was a no big no
big deal at the very least Trump you
know Fox News and these personnel were
talking about it Trump did put together
a travel restriction I mean what I would
I would I would put a finer point on it
not to disagree with you I would say
that everybody was proactively slowed
down by the agents that be in government
at the CDC and World Health Organization
because they
said this wasn't something to worry
about they said it was contained in
China the CDC said no no private
industry you can't step up with the test
so now we have a two-minute at-home test
and they're still lift is still stopping
them from reducing 160 thousand a day
capping it at a hundred thousand so
private industry could have moved
quickly they were stopped proactively by
the bureaucracy BC in the government
I got an you know right you know I say
it's I agree with you and then I said
but you know what I'll still give 90% of
the blame to China or more they lied
they downplayed this they withheld
information and and the World Health
Organization was just ponying up and
pushing their propaganda like that video
of the doctor shutting the skype off
when they gets asked about Taiwan is
this it's despicable gosh that was so
lame for people who don't know since
your quarter agent my lawyers talked
about this for people who don't
understand the sort of rivalry I guess
you would say the history between Taiwan
and China I mean it Argentina Brazil
soccer pale in comparison so the fact
that it's one of two things the World
Health Organization is either so
tone-deaf they have no idea as to what
it is you're about to educate us on with
Taiwan and China or they proactively
tried to hold Taiwan away from the talks
in conversation well I can't give you
the full history I'm not you know the
Taiwanese scholar anything but
essentially Taiwan order Asian you
should know something you eat red bean
ice cream
give me something Tim I'm tired there
the Taiwan it use themselves as
independent from China right China does
not agree there's been a major
international conflict
so when Hong Kong Hong Kong reporter
asked the doctor from the World Health
Organization how does he view you know
Taiwanese membership into the World
Health Organization he just ignores her
entirely this is completely toeing the
line for China and you know most people
in the u.s. respect Taiwan or I assume
Taiwan's independence we call them
Taiwan not China right and people in
Hong Kong recognize us as well so it's
it's it's similar like the South China
Sea yeah if you are a pro China shill
you'll be like that's China and you'll
put it in your movies and you'll do what
they do right you know the NBA players
and if you're not pro-china and oppose
the horrifying they do the things they
do to the we're Muslims in the camps and
the repression in Hong Kong you'll
you'll easily point out the people of
Taiwan want nothing to do with them
right so the World Health Organization
is toeing the line it would seem so
how can we trust them exactly and the
silver lining is here when you look at
the young turks and you look at all of
these leftist and I know that you're
more left on the idea of sort of some
sort of socialized health care plan or
more so or Universal some component to
it I don't want to misrepresent you but
I know we differ on that
however the argument has always been
made that well actually we have worse
health care were ranked 36 well we're
ranked right next to Slovenia and we are
you know who's ranked number to Italy
Spain is ranked number seven so right
now that ranking system which is based
primarily on subjective polling are you
satisfied with your health care from the
World Health Organization is no longer
valid the left can never point to it the
only other one that can point to is the
Commonwealth study that involved eleven
countries and had us ranked 11th and the
UK number one how's that working out for
them so hopefully people are at least
opening their eyes now going on a second
yeah the CDC and FDA really were slow
and mucked this up in private industry
even the my pillow rapist looking guy is
stepping in to pick up their slack
here's something I want to talk with you
about though Tim because you know this
probably better than anybody and I'm not
just blowing smoke the media bias and
the algorithms obviously that happened
across social media a big one of these
obviously was Laura Ingraham she put out
a tweet talking about chloroquine I
believe if I'm not mistaken yeah touting
it as a treatment and not saying cure by
the way talking about it as a treatment
the disturbance when a cure and
therapeutics and we've talked about that
on the show notice that our videos were
drastically throttled they had no reach
this was removed from Twitter as
misleading information now it's been
approved by the FDA as emergency
treatment is it just and I know there's
a little bit more nuance there and I
want you to describe it right is there a
worry here that the people who are
inputting these algorithms there's so
much selection bias before the
algorithms go out to you know to go out
to piranha piranha eyes that's a new
verb for news I think we're facing it's
gonna its we're gonna see our civil
liberties hit really really hard because
of this so to talk specifically about
the Laura Ingraham thing she said that
there was a doctor in Lenox Hill that
was using it and I believe that was
incorrect I couldn't find anything to
verify that there had been several
statements from a doctor in Lenox Hill
that was touting the the potential for
it in previous studies from what
understand he was a practicing physician
who had like something like admission
privileges in other words he wasn't a
full time staff at Lenox Hill but he did
work at Lenox Hill in some capacity yes
so they win on a technically the truth
right you know Trump comes out and says
hydroxyl Corps hydroxychloroquine and as
a therm Ison very promising he says it
might work it might not I'm very hopeful
the media tears him apart blames him for
a guy you know putting a spoonful of
fish tank cleaner in a soda meanwhile
Andrew Cuomo says the same thing that
completely ignored either way you know
that wife killed that husband that was
the fish tank cleaner she's the new
Carole bask and we can get into that
she's a huge democratic thing she's a
huge Democratic donor and was looking to
try and divorce the guy and then all of
a sudden he drank the fish tank cleaner
and she didn't it's speculation by the
way don't legal it's fake news but I'm
doing a deep dive spiraling what I get
tired I spiraled him continue to tip the
reins or I'm gonna mess this up what
were you talking about uh so the the
social media that's right all right I
just I saw that post from from James
O'Keefe Facebook took down his video
where he was literally just filming
going to New Rochelle to get a test yeah
like this is this is the new normal
there's a there's a progressive
commentator Cal kolinsky I think he's a
good dude and he tweeted that we're
there's not gonna be a back to normal
we're gonna see a pre and post Co vid
thing just like we did with 9/11 yeah
and I said and I think so and and we're
seeing major corporations justify
censoring people on social media like
Laura Ingraham and the president of
Brazil without question you know they
say well we'll label it misleading they
don't care heads of state are gone you
know high-profile pundits you're gone if
you don't say what they want you to say
yeah and what's scary is what's the real
criticism of James o keeffe's going and
filming what people think he was young
Matthew Modine it's it's that what
that's me was insane and to see like
these journalists cheering for it yeah
he asked a frontline guy like how do you
feel I used to do that all the time when
I would go down to like Egypt or Ukraine
and cover stuff on the ground I walk up
to a guy and say what's happening how do
you feel right and that's journalism to
them but if it counters their narrative
or goes against their machine so what
we're seeing now is you know hold that
thought one second here and I really
appreciate bring that up and yeah I am
familiar I think with with Calculon ski
from one he was one who didn't want to
debate a long time ago
we were much smaller channels but
hopefully listen I appreciate that I
think he someone like him and I would
disagree but he's being straightforward
about this hopefully he never uses the
world healthcare organizations rankings
again of that Commonwealth study we'll
see here's the for those who are
watching now everything's in front of
the pay wall because hashtag mug Club
quarantine this is the time where we
would leave go to break and say hey go
to mug club go to the blaze TV for web
extended but instead right now you could
see all of it so Indian color bars and
we're back here with Tim Poole okay Tim
continue what you were talking about
with the journalism so well what we're
specifically worried I got distracted
I don't know here's what I wanted to ask
you yeah she totally killed her yeah
yeah yeah essentially we're seeing for
one major corporations are justifying
taking things down Kara Swisher for the
New York Times write this op-ed saying
Fox News is dangerous you know campaign
and and it's it scared to me that there
are people who will read this not
realizing that it was the Washington
Post USA Today and all these other news
outlets that were saying the exact same
thing yeah a weird a weird thing
happened where you know early on a lot
of conservatives were in front of this
Tom cotton especially he's always been
in front of this and Fox News was but
then once the media latched onto it it
seems like there was this weird tribal
thing that happened the left didn't want
to concede that the conservatives were
right and beat him to calling this out
because Tom cotton was right
Facebook was apparently taking down his
statements in the Senate well let me
give you a straighter path to an
explanation here okay they're communists
and communist sympathizers and I always
say this because they were they were no
no think about this for a second it
sounds extreme they were complicit in
parroting the calm the check online
right that we have it contained it's
taken care of
don't worry about it so when that was
what they were saying the media went out
and said it's fine don't worry about it
like you say from Washington Post then
when the Chinese government said
actually we have it contained and it may
have come from the American government
and it's your fault guess what they
paired of that same line so if you want
to look at consistency they might as
well be walking out with the Chinese
communist governments handbook will
here's it's amazing Twitter thinks it's
unacceptable that Laura Ingraham put out
a tweet about hydroxychloroquine but
they find it except
well that a Chinese official tweeted
several times that it was the US
military doing it yeah foreign minister
Yes Minister yeah and he was also by the
way editing clips out of context where
it was some I don't have it in front of
me there was some kind of a Senate
hearing I don't remember but they were
interviewing doctors and the doctor was
saying that yes there were likely some
corona virus cases before March and they
were saying see it started in the United
States and it was covered up by the
military it's the kind of thing they
would have banned Alex Jones for a long
time ago here's something else I'd like
to ask you because we noticed this in
the first week when the corona virus
when the Cova da flu China Chinese virus
what if you want to call it I don't care
lose everything that offends everybody
here we noticed that nothing we put up
that related to corona virus was getting
anyplace for the first week and I mean
about less than a tenth of every other
video that we were uploading you know in
the months prior and then all of a
sudden I think maybe last week it was a
boom and people started saying
notifications were back in yeah and we
did you see any of that in your channel
no they they well I didn't cover this as
it was rising throughout February
because I was told straight up that it's
I wouldn't just be suppressed like what
when I tried talking about certain
issues related foreign policy I got a
hard notification that I was discussed
like I did a video about Trump's
approval rating and they call the
terrorism related and so I was told in
no one says that they also attribute
they also said that changed my mind
there was it changed my mind mail
privileges a myth yeah they said that
was election meddling right so yeah you
know what I think I think some there
there's people who work there who trying
their either there's their incompetence
there's malice and then eventually I get
these over these things overturned but
when I so on my on my second channel the
Tim Casa news one I had no problem
talking about this other than I have a
wall of confirm D monetization z-- and
the views were I would say down like 15
or 20 percent okay but I don't you know
I don't know to describe it I think
people go to my second channel I call my
second Channel they don't they're not
you're not searching for specific
information about it so it doesn't
matter if they hard suppress it to a
certain degree right my my flagship
channel the main one where I do the one
segment I tried to do
a video on it and then I get a
notification saying war conflict tragedy
terrorism right and when that happens I
get maybe like two to three percent of
normal viewership so I had no choice I'm
like this there's no point even
uploading it so I just take it down I
put up a different was that did that
with something coronavirus related you
had that okay so maybe that could be it
and my inbox is just so flooded right
now that I just didn't catch it where I
was going like how much and you know
what
I'm sorry glad do you have the
self-certification thing on YouTube just
like I don't sell certify I'm married
now yes well then but know that there's
a new program they launched and maybe
I'm just being callous not real I don't
know if your if you guys have monetized
back or whatever but they want me to you
Tim Poole I get I have this thing where
they tell me I have to tell them what's
in it and so when I made a video about
this here's a first on January 23rd I
made a video about this because China
was locking things down and it was
alarming not not a partisan American
politics thing I thought was important
and they said it was fine I asked me
does it contain any of these things hate
speech firearms booze whatever none of
these things yeah no war-related not
tear related they said you're good to go
they they manually review every video I
do no matter what whether it's monetized
or de monetized a week later they
reversed that and gave me a flag
striking the video confirming it D
monetized and suppressing it for the
next session up until like a week like
three or four days ago Wow they finally
agreed to overturn it okay because with
it what they told me was we've accepted
the reality of the coronavirus we're now
going to let you talk about it okay
think think about how many people could
have been warned if you didn't suppress
my content right and this is a perfect
example of the media wins on a
technicality in getting Laura Ingram's
tweet taken down because the Lenox Hill
doctor is not technically on retainer at
Lenox Hill he just has I think
outpatient uh I don't know how patient
privileges but we would say that maybe
would be a better win for the media if
they actually educated the American
public on a potential
very efficient treatment that's been
approved by the FDA it's almost like
that should be more important for the
media to try and focus on this what I
love what they do
what was it March 19th TechCrunch Hydrox
hydroxychloroquine azithromycin shows
promising results Donald Trump comes out
two days later I heard the story here
that's amazing Donald Trump lies pushes
conspiracy it's like the the media
reports at Andrew Cuomo March 6 masks
are being stolen Trump comes out a
couple days ago maybe the masses are
being stolen Trump pushes conspiracies
it's like you guys reported this first
right they were poured it Trump repeats
it then they call it a lie I don't
understand how they think well they're
not getting away with that anymore the
people starting to see through this and
Trump's approval rating is going up well
and I really appreciate genuinely people
like you are out there who I don't
believe you were a Trump voter or
certainly you weren't noticed and the
fact that you were actually out there
being objective it when people talk
about common ground I would say hey
listen truth is more important than
common ground for example you and I
disagree on some issues but we can find
common ground as we do right now without
actually having to agree final question
I wanted to ask you about this because
of the the quarter Asian which by the
way you fool people beautifully like you
could go into an Abercrombie ad just get
yourself a spray tan and claim any
ethnicity it's wonderful right it is
true I don't have that I'll briefly
mention I was in Egypt and the people
there thought I was a Gyptian
sure I go to I got to Mexico I think I'm
Spanish like no one I'm ambiguous yeah
like sort of blend in anywhere and you
could going with white people and they
don't care like as I was saying so the
do you think that the FDA did the right
thing in refusing the masks from China
knowing what we know now because that
was another thing that was covered by
the media as a huge problem probably I
you know I've been hearing stories that
we get tons of goods from them that's
contaminated with a ton of really nasty
stuff that we have to reject all the
time right and you know I guess it's a
tough call if 10% work is it worth
taking them I don't know probably not
they're trying to exploit the situation
for academic gain they've been lying to
us and it's about time we bring on the
manufacturing back here and you and you
know that when it comes to the idea of
being objective that's what people like
to say and I'm like like you said the
truth is more important Trump was right
about China and manufacturing and all
that and if we had listened and moved
much more quickly in the past few years
we wouldn't be straight
for medical supplies that's just a fact
no I think you're absolutely right mr.
Poole in closing what would you want
people to see as a silver lining in all
of this like where should they look to
or what do you think is hopeful in this
scenario because a lot of people see it
as looking bleak they're they're you
know I hate to point out positives in a
bleak situation it's in certain
circumstances but it should be said that
I think this will help make us stronger
I think we bring manufacturing back we
have better border security we take very
seriously the need for just community
and working together and fighting
together we're now saying something
incredible we're D prioritizing the BS
you know in economics like celebrities
are being mocked and ridiculed by you
know across the board Ren doctors and
nurses truck drivers are being
championed these jobs that are actually
important for all of us so you know you
know I've been saying is that a lot of
these social justice fantasies you know
that people saying it's violence to
insult to call me a name these the it's
all now being erased when people realize
it was only possible to say those things
because you lived in a safety bubble
right now that we have a real threat all
of that stuff is starting to disappear
because it's not relevant - none of it
was true in the first place so that's a
silver lining you'll get people back to
responsibility and you know independence
individuality I think but also in turn
us community we gotta bring our
manufacturing back 100%
yeah and I think I think another I mean
I think that's a silver lining and I
think a very uncomfortable truth is that
people are realizing that folks who many
Americans thought had their best
interests at heart
genuinely don't I hate that this is what
has been required to wake up some folks
but I think you see it pretty clear with
the stark contrast in the second Donald
Trump is able to speak directly to the
American people with his briefings his
approval ratings go on and in record
time by the way and so immediately the
network's stopped airing it to me most
people go okay you know what I don't
even like the guy but he still is the
president right now when you guy said
this is the worst pandemic of our
lifetime we should probably hear from
the president and of course his cabinet
and medical specialists who are up there
did you see that that that Rose Garden
interaction where the I think with a CNN
journalist says you said I want to be
appreciated and then not to call people
and Trump says read the
whole quote I was III see this stuff all
the time I'm used to it but I was still
shocked by what the actual quote was
right Trump saying I'm not talking about
me I'm talking about the administration
and the people working hard I'm like yes
they should be as well and the media cut
that out and you know that's really hard
for Trump to say so it makes him even
madder you know him say yeah that's a
good that I'm not saying this about me
and then is like you still don't give me
credit
same exact thing we're talking about we
said it's amazing to me that we are that
were throwing away these masks we have
we should have ways to sanitize we have
very and this is Ray sounds like a
buffoon fine liquids what he means is we
have a sanitization and process which we
now know by the way could make up to
400,000 masks add a reusable 20 times
recycling this is something that should
be championed by the fat lesbians at
BuzzFeed on youtubes homepage
immediately recycling man listen it's
it's not conservative or liberal to
point out that there's a potential
treatment or masks can be reused and
this is what I think a lot of the
tribalists left don't like about me or
why that accuse me of being conservative
it's like hey the American people really
like what Donald Trump is doing what
he's saying and they're like well only a
trump supporter would say good things
about him know if the polls are showing
it Donald Trump lied about masks that so
I'm like what Andrew Cuomo said it -
it's not a conservative position to call
out mask theft would right it's it's it
no one's arguing policy in these stories
you know tribalism
to them it's not about whether you agree
with social policy or not it's whether
or not you're on my team yes but it is a
liberal position for Cuomo to be
governor with nipple barbells so the
channel is Tim Poole there's Tim cast
and then Tim cast news on the Twitter
for as long as is allowable at Tim cast
hey Tim Poole thank you so much for
being here man we always appreciate it
and stay safe wash your hands
well there's likewise we're gonna wrap
this up
[Music]
estoy seguro de que están esperando que
habla de la gran selection the café's
que pueden in contrar cuando a drone a
poor black rifle coffee cata Granny o
estado de to individual la mejor es
cranio stay mundo IDO hablar por horas
como es parado
por veteran o si la casa que apoya pero
para me son las Casas pequeña esta la
vida
como me Haro the medium roast amina the
black rifle coffee dot-com / brother use
promo code browser for 20% off your
first purchase hey you know about black
rifle coffee and hopefully you're
drinking black rifle coffee but
something else i want to let you know
they're doing a coffee donation campaign
right now not only do they support this
show but they're helping support medical
workers first responders emergency
service workers and they're actually
doing kind of one of those buy a bag
give a bag because what do they need
sure they need masks they need medical
supplies but if they're dropping
overtired like a narcoleptic they're not
any good to anybody so what they need is
coffee and you know there's some
companies out there that talk about what
they do as far as causes and it's a
marketing gimmick black rifle is veteran
owned and operate and they give a
certain percentage of their proceeds to
veteran causes but they've stepped up
several times like this with disasters
so they put their money where their
mouth is and all that's great
it wouldn't mean a damn thing if the
coffee wasn't better than the
competition so go to black rifle coffee
comm slash Crowder enter in the promo
code Crowder and you get 20% off your
first purchase and listen you get to
help some people who are out there doing
the real work this is me making fart
jokes in a microphone
[Music]
ladder with Crowder Ranger pen buy yours
today at louder with prouder shop cop
[Music]
that's called the drowning dance looking
at the clock because I just don't care
anymore it's been a long week
Thank You Janice Lou you guys saw the
web extended and of course a lot of
these things are just um they're always
behind the paywall
people who are not most you know that's
what we're I mean probably most of the
time my headphones got a lot of sand
okay now I have the hard way and I
really AM great like we were talking
about this if people are losing their
jobs and five million for unemployment
out there like you know haven't up the
workload really isn't isn't all that
much skin off my nose but I looked at
the clock and I can't believe it's still
today it's only it's not a Friday it
feels I don't wanna say it feels like a
Friday it feels like I wish it were a
Friday I think it's like you guys get to
you know you get to watch and spend time
with us but I don't get to see you right
so you watch and you yeah but we don't
see you I mean right now you should put
a sticky note on that but I don't see
all of you and so like you know I'm
doing them we're doing twice the
workload and just hoping it works yeah
hours put in that yellow submarine
maybe crap we don't know I have no idea
but we have a lot next week I believe we
have a bunch of guests of course Monday
Wednesday Friday we're doing good
morning mug Club live where you can chat
with us every morning 10:00 a.m. Eastern
and then we have a clips on YouTube
every night if you're not interested in
the $30 off quarantine code from my club
but that is what will keep us afloat
yeah during and after this a lot of not
a lot of so unfortunately some
conservative organizations out there
you've probably reading some of the news
they've been laying some people off and
and I hope that that bounces back but
that's because a lot of people are
dependent on ad revenue out there right
now and particularly like Google Adsense
or websites the problem with that is a
lot of those businesses or smaller
businesses running ads and they can't
afford it the first internet cut off is
his advertiser stuff and we're primarily
funded by viewers like you you guys get
this wonderful mug and you don't have to
support a foreign caliphate so we will
see you next week it's going all Mon
smoke low quarantine but you know I
wanted to talk about something
touching this with with Tim pools a
little bit and Tim Poole and I have
talked all fair full disclosure we're
not part of some secret cabal we just
every now and then he's like hey did you
hear this I mean I didn't hear that did
you hear this you know okay I'll talk to
you about it next week that's about it
we're not wearing pointy hats there are
no owls involved you know nothing like
that no burning anything in effigy
but um sir we disagree on a whole lot
politically and that's one like he's not
one of those guys who's really
conservative of trying to claim that
he's still liberal he's really not a
conservative which I appreciate he was
like we can find what we find common
ground and I was wondering you know why
when people talk about the political
division they're not really complaining
about political division because that
has existed always pretty much right you
can go back and watch films from the
5060 70s where they say a Republican
Democrat they kind of rib each other
right people have divided along
ideological lines since the beginning of
time in the United States Republican
Democrats since we have a two-party
system that's kind of that's kind of an
important way because you're signing on
to a platform that being said you can
find common ground right without meeting
in the middle that's something that I
think people get wrong it doesn't mean
that oh we're gonna compromise and meet
in the middle no no you can be a
conservative a hard-line conservative
and you can be a far left liberal and
you find common ground without II agree
on anything political and what does that
mean we're talking about common ground
it's because really what you're finding
common ground with should be principles
or moral through lines that we share in
other words the idea of freedom over the
individual freedom of the individual
sorry over the collective or the idea
that for example families will look out
for themselves before they look out for
some foreign country or entity or the
idea that a country that allows people
to be free and ended slavery that's a
better thing than a country that still
employs slavery because not all moral
outlooks in the world are equivalent
these are moral through lines that
Democrats and Republicans at one point
shared even though they disagreed wildly
on tax policy foreign policy and even
abortion why is it so hard to do right
now
here's why because the basis of finding
common ground and it can be the only
basis it has to be founded on truth you
have to come to some kind of agreement
as to what the truth is and that's not
what's happening right now that's why
you have a media that refuses to run
press conferences and then cherry-pick
information from those press conferences
and then present it this is amazing I
was reading it this morning as reading a
story I don't member where it was and
but one second they're saying that
Donald Trump is running press
conferences on tap to try and downplay
coronavirus and then they cite the 100
to 200 thousand deaths from from Burks
and they got that number from the press
conference when Donald Trump said ok
doctor you had to tell them and then
they go Donald Trump doesn't want to
acknowledge this hold on a second yeah
that's why they don't want to run these
because I don't want us to find common
ground on truth they're there's a
silver lining in this right now there
should be a silver lining that we could
come together like we did after 9/11
right all Americans hand-in-hand that we
are the world but we are America against
an invisible enemy and you know what
when that happens when you're going to
war and I've heard people describe this
as a war against an invisible adversary
when you're going into battle you do
need to recognize the victories that
matters you've heard of the term morale
that's important it's important for a
leader and obviously Donald Trump is a
president a leader and that's why he's
tried to focus on that and gosh that's
horrible we should shame the president
for saying anything positive but you
know who else was in a position of
leadership is not just a president it's
not just Washington DC I've said this
before if you were to take the power of
Washington DC over the power of
Hollywood and the media you need a
cat-scan
they are in a position of leadership
they don't talk about any of the
victories recyclable masks hundreds of
thousands five-minute tests two-minute
tests at-home test therapies some places
over 90% efficacy rate none of it and
here's what we're trying to find a
silver lining right now when we talk
about common ground here's why we can't
find common ground and we don't need a
budge on this we meaning Americans and I
mean even Bernie voters Americans who
actually believe in the eye
in concept of the United States of
America you know what let's take it one
step further let's say you don't believe
that the United States is the greatest
country even that good of a country you
don't want to see it go away you just
want to see Americans survive
you just want Americans to have hope
well guess what we can all find a silver
lining there together in common ground
in the idea that we're making progress
and the idea that the mortality rates
are going down as we increase testing as
we increase efficiency of testing as we
hopefully have more private industry
step up as we're able to use more masks
as we're able to sanitize more masks we
can find common ground on that because
there's common ground on a silver lining
which is the truth but here's the thing
if the silver lining is a lie it's
meeting with us and unfortunately right
now the silver lining that we have in
the media who should be looking out for
the best interest of the American public
right that is that is our job the idea
of just the facts that's a slogan from
CNN just the facts well just the facts
would mean that you're looking out for
the best interests of the American
public that you want them to be able to
make an informed decision but the truth
is the silver lining that they are
looking for right now is a way to blame
it on Republicans and the president
after Russia and an impeachment didn't
work and after parroting the Communist
Chinese government line verbatim didn't
work so the silver lining that we're
looking for is Americans is how are we
going to come out of this how severe is
it what kind of risk factor are we
looking at what do we need to do with
mom and dad and grandpa and grandma oh
we're looking for a silver light well
that's good news
okay here's some productive measures
that we can take at that exact same time
the people we can't find common ground
with those in charge of the media
entertainment industrial complex are
going where's the silver lining here how
do we blame Republicans and Trump and
Christians and guess what we don't need
to find common ground with those folks
what we need to do is focus on finding
common ground in the truth otherwise the
silver lining means nothing because it's
a lie
I don't have anything productive to
offer you as far as advice read the news
fat check say your prayers and set a
guard but there's a lot of good
happening out there right now and you're
not going to hear of it if you're tuning
into the main networks that's why we're
here doubling the content for mug Club
quarantine or we're giving you a promo
code $30 off join if you want to support
it if you don't watch for free we
appreciate you being there we hope that
someday you do support us so we can be
here for years to come finding silver
linings see you next not next week see
you tomorrow morning
oh god it's still today and we have a
tomorrow
[Music]